hey there welcome to con Brian needs a
friend joined by my Compadres
compatriots uh Sona Oban there you go
took a second and then Mt gorley how are
you I'm pretty good how are you U I'm
doing all right I think I'm doing fine
yeah you know how are you son I'm okay
just okay yeah I'm fine is it my mic on
no it's not your mic isn't on did you do
that on purpose I didn't do anything
it's okay it's okay wait Eduardo Edo
messed up Eduardo what happened there
one time I go drink some water I drink
some water what do you mean
water I was like oh I forgot her mic was
not on WE record wasn't on that's we
recording we were recording we are
recording you know this is why you lost
your job as an air traffic
controller cuz he kept turning their
mics off I'm sorry Sona no no supposed
to be a professional organization and
Eduardo here who I admire who built this
studio I know you gave me a gift cuz I
don't think he has anything to to harp
on you about and now you now he didn't
turn my mic on I do have something good
to talk about huh the other night uh
some friends of my wife and I were
having dinner at like kind of a fancy
restaurant and it was in Beverly Hills
which we did we never go into that part
of town like I'm not a guy that goes to
restaurants in Beverly Hills you're not
a BH guy I'm not um and so we go there
and we have this really nice meal with
our friends and I'm like oh this is
great this place is terrific and then
we're about to leave and this gentleman
comes up to me who I think works with
the restaurant and he says Mr O'Brien
I'm here to walk you through the walk
you walk you past the paparazzi and I
said what cuz like I'm like what are you
talking about paparazzi that's not you
know and he's like no no I'm here to
make sure that you get through the
paparazzi okay and I'll walk you back to
your car and and I'm like with my wife
like well that's weird okay we walk
outside
nobody I mean not just no paparazzi no
people it was like they were shooting
Omega Man you know like a
post-apocalyptic and I wasn't I was and
and then and then so now that I have the
added thing of like this guy's with me
and he's kind of acting like right this
way just keep moving like what are you
talking about hey it's me I don't have
I'm not someone who's like why don't
they leave me alone but it was so funny
and this guy never acknowledged like
well he never acknowledged that oh I
thought there was or I just assumed
because you're a known person that there
would be you know and I was assuming
that he knew that you know and so and
but he' still he never let on he was
just like keep right this way where's
which one's your car and he committed
the whole way the whole way it was just
I thought it was so it was so perfect it
was so me like Mr Brian I'm here to help
you through the paparazzi huh what well
if you say so doors fly open
tumble weed tumble weed went by with a
long lens
camera but not aimed at me it was really
funny for your birthday we should get
you Paparazzi I think that'd be nice
yeah that'd be that would be yeah real
Paparazzi no no no people fake people no
cuz realy wouldn't come every Christmas
season it's the same thing demands for
more podcast episode comes in and we've
got to meet those demands we got to mail
out those podcasts we got to get them in
the mail guess with stamps.com all you
need is a computer and printer then
you're ready for that Holiday Rush you
know what I'm saying no remember last
year when we were stuffing podcast into
envelopes and licking them and putting
on the stamps it was crazy in here no
more not with stamps.com they even send
you a free scale so you have everything
you need to get started cuz whenever I
go to mail stuff out I'm like where's my
scale well they got the scale ready
there for you now taking care of orders
on the go is even easier with the
stamps.com mobile app if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
it through your stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart get your business ready
for the holiday Rush get started with
stamps.com today sign up at stamps.com
Conan for a special offer that includes
a 4-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Conan I did do a thing that
was really funny there was uh uh a
period uh in my life when sometimes
there would be uh you know people around
and I wanted to normalize that for my
kids so what I would do is when my kids
were little I would uh I would I I told
them I taught them this bit but we would
walk out and it'd be it'd be some
restaurant you know that where there
aren't anybody there's nobody there's
nobody there there's no Paparazzi but we
would walk out and my kids who were
little this is like my daughter was like
maybe seven and my son was five they
would both fan out and say back up back
up leave alone and there was nobody
there and they it was it was fun cuz it
it was a making fun of me yeah about no
one gives a about our dad and then
uh but I just love to see little kids
going please he's a person give him room
but I don't know I don't know where this
guy got in his head maybe he just
assumed like well we've had other famous
people here and it's a mob scene out you
know we we just had you know whatever uh
Travis if that I would feel embarrassed
that there wasn't a crowd but also
embarrassing that you're making this guy
work for nothing I didn't well yeah I
tipped this gentleman cuz I felt like he
got just walked me that's why he's doing
it I know but I just felt bad I I just I
didn't know what to think I thought this
is this is uh please I'm here to help
you it's a mom president yeah yeah uh we
just had uh we just had Taylor Swift and
Travis were here and uh you know we know
how it can be so we're going to walk you
to your
car
what I always I always in those moments
when things are really quiet I always I
always want a bird to go
by like a mocking
bird would it have been worse if there
was just like one person there and they
cuz oh yeah I've been with you when Pop
Ry and they cuz there's nothing about
your life that's exciting always doing
so they're like hey what do you think
about you know oh buying a horse yeah
they always have to try and think of
something and they don't have a question
ready to go for me so they're always you
know um stock
market interest what did you buy at the
CVS oh I got those caps that you put on
a toothbrush that sort of keep other
things from brushing up against
it and then you just know TMZ's like
Conan sucks
Bang
write this way Mr O'Brien we got you
[Music]
back a horse goes by hey it's Conan
oan used to be on the
television and then the pop rzi goes wow
a talking horse they start taking
pictures of
him